what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch the
finale for season three of Brooklyn nine
nine today John how are you I am I'm
good I'm excited I'm a little sad yeah
I'm a little sad a little sad guys
leave a like
leave a sad like
and uh yeah
all right let's watch the show let's
get to it
[Music]
come on come on Captain pick up your
friend Bob is secretly working for Jimmy
The Butcher figures this is a call
you're going to want to take Bob must
have done something to him or maybe
they're talking about something super
boring like potatoes or beans white rice
some of the Rices I love
um also Basmati yeah when he comes out
of the coma we'll get him to talk am I
getting us some food I can't fathom
eating these candies that Peralta bought
us chocolate is the devil's carob and
carob is Satan's raisin
oh Raymond I forgot my wallet in my
um you've killed him damn now I'm going
to have to kill you
[Music]
I've never been more shocked that wasn't
the line or
was that the line that preceded
yeah yeah I don't remember
something's missing rewind the tape
where would Bob have taken hope I don't
know the library or an index card
Factory is there such a thing as an
accounting Museum hold on I got this I
know the captains find my phone password
he's at the hospital
we gotta get to the hospital and we
gotta get there fast then I should drive
why you I have nothing to live for and I
drive like it okay let's do it
what are you doing
I'm breaking the law Raymond because I'm
the worst now walk out of this room as
if nothing is happening
you'll never get away with it
I know the real Jake he's like a son to
me and when this is all through we're
going on a road trip together Jake Rosa
I'm working on the case right now it's
like they're both here
there's a smudge on this sign right over
the H there's a smudge on this H2 oh my
God why would you touch a hospital thing
and then put it in your mouth it's
chocolate great instincts never doubt
yourself
now all we have to do is follow the
trail of chocolate this is why I became
a cop really Live Your Dream I don't
care what you have to do today you sweet
thing you're pregnant
So Pregnant what a miracle right please
give me special treatment I ripped her a
new one and guess what fell out
it's Captain Holt where is he what did
he say in a brew tid when I'm getting
another one incubs Wiz these are
nonsense in a broom closet all right you
might figure it out he's secretly trying
to text us from his pocket when I die
please give Kevin my regards
what shall I tell him
regards
[Laughter]
it came out I'm on Rouge I'm on the roof
Scully and your weird dead hands you
would Hitchcock or kill
[Laughter]
what are you doing up here why are you
on the roof actually I was gonna throw
Raymond over the side and make it look
like a bird watching accident please do
you think anyone's gonna ask it's a
genius there's a red-tailed hawk Roost a
block away and I've got a pair of
microbinoculars in my pocket like a fool
that file's in a safe place and you're
never getting it don't be foolish Bob
you're outnumbered outnumbered my bottom
because this men are on the way yes I
call for backup get me down
[Music]
oh my goodness
nice timing Sarge how'd you know we were
up here Captain Mark the H is in
chocolate which I instantly connected to
the giant helipad H world right now
we have to call for backup Vegas has
people in the NYPD and the FBI so good
luck with that well betraying the FBI is
one thing but sarcasm Bob wow
we can go to my apartment no one knows
where I live I thought you had Amy over
there once yeah it was fun I moved the
next day
what if we didn't look like cops
yeah buddy wow Sarge you are just
stepped into those scrubs how do you do
it exercise and diet it's not that hard
seems pretty hard to me I don't think
I'm gonna do that
I love playing doctor as a child the
cancer is spread
get your house in order
yep
and yes he is bound and gagged under
there but more importantly you said What
About Bob that's the name of a movie
hold made a pop culture reference all
right let's go Bill Murray Richard
Dreyfuss you said he's crashing here's a
syringe oh good I'll use this to
puncture his skin oh we got company uh
this man has a bomb in his butt we gotta
go
oh
we're gonna embrace the spiral
we're gonna talk about these fears
things about to get real excuse me ma'am
yes we're gonna need a box of tissues
and some cozy blankets okay oh one more
thing we all got sundaes
oh I wish on an airplane
that's what this is yeah relax there's a
million ways to get out of a hospital
unnoticed name one
dress up like babies
[Laughter]
damn snap Bob
oh I'm an FBI agent I am Serena Williams
I'm sorry they both suffer from
grandiose delusional disorder gdd I've
been taking hostage here and I'm
supposed to be at Wimbledon
we need to transfer them both to a
secure psychiatric facility Serena here
just bit off a doctor's nose he tasted
delicious
yeah you can go no no call the FBI don't
call me
[Laughter]
well played good plan I guarantee you
soldiers find this place not gonna
happen I rented out under a shell
Corporation yeah my mail goes to appeal
box in Queens yeah my neighbors think my
name is Emily goldfish oh yeah people I
work with I'll think my name is Rosa
Diaz yeah wait what don't worry about it
okay
[Laughter]
who are you
I love him so much
oh my god I've said I love you to him
before but I've never added so much what
if I never get to say so much what about
me what if something happens to Jake and
he never gets to meet my baby I don't
want to hang out with some stupid babies
never met Jake
I'm under your skin the only thing's
under my skin are oil glands hair bulbs
nerve fibers blood vessels and a bit of
fatty tissue you forgot about rufini's
corpuscle oh my God you're rattled I
don't think that was as vicious a bird
as he thinks he beat me it's over
[Laughter]
it's over
you want to play hardball good word on
the street is you like jazz I don't just
like jazz I'm fond of it tell me where
the file is right now or I will ruin
Jazz for you forever skip it up and Jazz
Jazzy jazz
Jews old Jazz jizz change
let me tell your kids man
that their daddy's a crook I don't have
any kids
the whole thing was based on you having
kids
now all of this is going to be
hypothetical
yeah here are five stories about my
cousin Leanne and her alleged Lyme
disease How's that gonna make me talk
not everything's about you Bob I just
needed to vent God you're such a lance
no swords
she's gonna look up at you
hypothetical tears
that's that Deputy dude super simple
what just happened somebody got the
power time's up
looks like fig is found you
damn it's called Summer's kiss
I hate to rub it in detectives but I
told you they'd find me sniper everybody
down
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa wrong guy wrong
guy
now you have to confess
you know you're Expendable what's going
on they tried to kill me
[Music]
the file is in a safe deposit box the
keys are in my car and the lining of my
trunk all right fine take Bob with you
into the Panic Room Rose and I'll find
another way out I'm sure you will son
you 'll be sun no take backs
[Laughter]
was it worth it of course I made
Millions I traveled the world I've eaten
whale I always assumed whale would be
too fatty well I don't have to assume I
know for a fact it is that's disgusting
I threw up
oh well this is my best friend Charles
and this is my girlfriend Amy she's not
really pregnant we're taking things slow
but it's going really good Jake right
they arrived about an hour ago sir oh my
God 410 is Emily Goldfinch who a curly
black hair always smiling a little
chatty for my taste
you were cowering in the Panic Room I
went and got this file to make sure you
weren't lying well what happened in here
it looks like there was a fight oh it
was
me
I was done with this place the minute
you all stepped foot in it oops
that's my girl
[Laughter]
Jake Peralta for three years without
knowing what the Funky Cold Medina is oh
hell yeah I asked the guy why you so fly
he said Funky Cold Medina
Funky Cold Medina zero rehearsal
[Laughter]
they've arrested over 75 of figures as
men his operation is decimated wow jeez
even when Bob held that gun to my head I
was not afraid because I knew you were
on the case
I respect the hell out of each and every
one of you
nine nine nine nine nine
so Charles and I really got into it on
the plane and around Sunday number five
I realized
we should move in together you and
Charles
I love you so much
I love you so much too
I love this so much
so I guess Charles was listening to our
conversation yeah yeah oop I'm gonna get
this
figures this is Jimmy figgis how you and
Ray Holt took down my operation now I'm
gonna kill you both uh Captain Holt
blue skies they're in Florida no
Blue Skies
[Music]
morning Greg
good morning Larry
what did Kevin and Amy come
not a doctor so they went into the
witness protection program what yeah I
guess so and then the show ended the
show just ended right here season three
it's bizarre yeah it's bizarre how
bizarre how bizarre damn dude that was a
hell of a cliffhanger that was quite a
cliffhanger dang
too bad they never got to continue the
show bummer I was so excited for the
prospect of a season four
that's all over now guys
that's all over
but we'll talk about what we got so far
that was hilarious that was hilarious
truly and clever it's a very clever
episode with a lot of good like I like
uh you know that Nolan thing uh a play
with time Christopher Owens who I'm
talking about not Nolan North voiceover
actor for Nathan Drake yes and uh
Uncharted series I'm sorry Christopher
Nolan and uh the the the way they mess
with time lets a lot of good twists and
turns and especially the ending reveal
that was great I I did not suspect that
at all nah really looks like there was a
sniper in the room and then because I
was I was like ah that b story is all
right with them trying to you know get
back to New York City
and it was and whatever but and there
was like a couple really funny moments
in there a couple of really really funny
lines
especially the one about I don't want my
stupid baby I was a stupid baby who's
never met Jake that's a really funny
yeah
um but then to have it wrap around at
that I thought was uh very very clever
because I was sold on the whole thing of
oh dad they're trying to kill him so now
he's going to confess like they they
have the obvious turn happen
then they really surprised us and then
you got some good cathartic moments with
Holt calling him son and then him
knowing the song like there's a lot of
really good stuff and I like that
mystery Intrigue of uh Rosa finding out
her names I don't even be Rosa oh yeah
that she's actually got a whole other uh
uh secret identity like she lives so
under the radar I thought that was that
was really really funny episode really
good stuff with a surprising Cliffhanger
real real surprising Cliffhanger really
well done well done show show did good
show did well did great it's almost as
uh surprising as the time Andy went or I
should say Jake went into uh undercover
work for figus's operation
is a big old uh yeah I mean I I guess I
would imagine that in a in a
hypothetical season four because they
never progressed the show past this
point I'd have to imagine that would
make for an interesting like couple of
opening episodes before things
hypothetically got back to hypothetical
normal after that
you know knowing this show they probably
spend like one or two episodes in
Florida and then they go back that's it
yeah we're right back to business yeah
no I I completely agree that this was uh
firing on most all the cylinders it was
a great just reminder of how great The
Ensemble is together how funny the
characters are on their own I thought
the whole thing where everyone's taking
a crack at trying to interrogate Bob was
pretty fun and uh and yeah like even
though it is a fun and fanciful show at
the same time I thought this episode did
nicely to balance that with just the
sort of fun intensity of the actual
situation when all the figures goons are
in the hospital and you've also got
Hospital people around who are like can
I help you you know I felt some of that
like frantic uh feeling you know that
frantic nature of the situation
and uh yeah
oh sometimes I get a frantic feeling
that's true yeah yeah I do
and a good feeling and uh you know
the laughter feeling I would have loved
to have seen like a real dark gritty
Escape scene a runner all the way out to
the hospital
yeah yeah I want her following all the H
smudges and the H smudges I thought that
was a clever gag too hiding behind walls
shooting people grabbing items from off
the counter sneaking up on people
slicing their throats breaking all the
way down sneaking Mission yeah like a
full-on sneaky Mission over the shoulder
mounted camera like a third person game
yeah picking up supplies yes
sound objects turn them into weapons
yeah so good keep that health bar High
yeah pick up some armor enter a cheat
code beat the game maybe look up some
codes on yeah surpass a sort of level
like what is the code to unlock the
stores thing if I beat the hospital five
times it'll unlock unlimited ammo mode
chasing in an ambulance oh yeah are you
gonna play as the character do a little
driving right yeah computer head out the
window fire Bam Bam
that'd be cool shoot off screen to
reload helicopter chase yeah it's a
launcher get your uh you know uh your
wanted level up to five stars yeah
that'd be awesome totally dude
next season it's gonna be good that's
what they're gonna do
this is going to be all of you
can we release season four as a video
game
so there's still the jokes you love it's
just you're gonna have to guide the
story now
choose your player
yeah man
I love that running gag with Rosa I
thought that was very like they've
they've done things like that before but
I thought the way that kept evolving
just makes her hotter it's quite funny
yeah it does does Mystery Woman
it's Jason manzukas didn't come back
not yet he might still though
if I was writing this I would have him
come back with his head in a box oh like
in uh like
don't ruin it that Brad Pitt gets his
head cut off and it gets shipped to
Morgan Freeman at his home and he's like
oh what's this here that's why Kevin
Spacey's like what's in the box what's
in the box in the Gwyneth Paltrow walks
in and he's like would you all keep it
down I'm waiting for my husband Brad
Pitt to come waiting for my husband Brad
Pitt either of you seen him I am going
to wring his neck with his head on it if
I get a hold of him anytime soon
what's in that box over there what is
that what boxes why is it dripping some
goo what's going on here it looks like
rare is there some kind of Otter Pops in
that box
they're all red yeah so don't we don't
want to sorry to ruin the ending of
seven for you guys but that's what
happens yeah I'm so sorry guys
we've had a few years to catch up with
seven yeah so sorry for the spoiler but
uh yeah it's all finale
um really funny all around yeah I like
the pay I do like the payoffs a lot
especially with um
especially with uh
I keep wanting to call them Andy because
of what you said and you correct
yourself and I'm forgetting with the
actual characters
so you guys will be with what Jake
Peralta said when he's like
impersonating them he's like he's like
the sun I never had yes yeah and he's
actually yeah he seems like not a smart
cop but he is and then he actually pulls
off something smart that was really
that's a good character moment of of the
character being self-aware but in a
funny that's like who plays Vegas let's
do oh yes let's spoil that's for
ourselves do it
hypothetically who would have played
figures had the show continued Beyond
this point oh John Malkovich John
Malkovich is the right that's I've
always wanted to see him on a sitcom you
know
and wasn't he one of the stars of The
Big Bang Theory that's right but you
know Big Bang Theory I just I only found
like slightly hilarious whereas I need
to see him in like a full-on top-tier
hilarious comedy to really judge his job
I think he was Chandler on Friends he
was
and it's almost to that level of iconic
comedy but just not quite there that's
what I'm saying even his work on Two and
a Half Men just does not come close no
no I mean it also didn't make sense that
he was the son of Jon Cryer yes
it didn't make sense he was the half man
it's okay though John Malkovich he
disappears into a lot of roles
including figures on this show
all right guys we did it we watched
Brooklyn nine nine we're officially done
with the whole series we're all caught
up
and uh maybe they'll reboot it maybe one
day they'll reboot it and if they do
maybe we'll continue watching it
um but who knows people might have lost
interest by that time I don't think so
all right guys we'll see you all soon
glad to complete another show
take care
[Music]